my next guest is a former monk turned
bestselling author that doesn't happen
every day his podcast on purpose with
Jay shett is the number one Health
podcast on the planet he's interviewed
everyone from President Biden to Oprah
Winfrey he's even interviewed the man
sitting next to me that can sing lies
and deception please welcome Jay Shetty
everybody
[Applause]
you I I have to lead with this you have
the most beautiful eyes ever they are
like oh thank you so beautiful well I
can't take any credit for them well done
god um have you all met before you know
each other right obviously okay okay
yeah I've had the fortun Met person we
did just earlier today but I've had
Dwayne on the show and we actually did
it virtually through zoom and the
connection was bad and all this kind of
stuff his Spirit still came through so
it was beautiful you were phenomenal
thank you so much have you always been
good at public speaking definitely not
okay I'm I get nervous oh my gosh I need
to tell you a story about my first ever
time public speaking I was 7 years old
there was an assembly at school a
cultural assembly and my mother loved to
see me on stage so she dressed me up in
a traditional Indian outfit parts of me
were falling out and then she'd asked me
to sing I have a horrific singing voice
she'd asked me to sing something in my
native language on stage in front of my
school so I get up there I start singing
and talking and singing and everyone
bursts out laughing everyone I'm glad
you didn't start laughing right now and
then I forgot the words so I looked down
to see if I could read the words and I
couldn't because my tears had smudged
the words and so then I forgot the words
and everyone started laughing more this
is the worst story ever and then to make
it worse my teacher came on stage put
her arm around me oh no and walked me
off stage and that was my first
experience of public speaking so and
you're here you are now this is
incredible you can do anything I know
I'm just saying like the fact that that
didn't deter you and you were like I've
got this oh my gosh yeah it was painful
I don't know if I'd ever speak in public
again I know that's what it felt like
well Jay spent 3 years as a Hindu Monk
and later wrote a best-selling book
called think like a monk so you've
talked a lot about why you became a monk
but not why you maybe got out so why why
what was the reason well I was learning
just so many incredible insights about
mindfulness and meditation and I really
had this hunger and desire to share it
with the world but at the time now it
makes sense but back then I was actually
quite scared when I came back to London
and I was stuck about where to start and
I remember talking to one of my mentors
and saying I have so many ideas about
how to help people but I don't know how
to get started and I'm guessing some of
you have felt that that way before and
he gave me some brilliant advice I'd
love to share with you yeah he said to
me that Jay you should try and open
every door you possibly can some of the
doors will close on you and you should
let them close but the doors that remain
open those are the ones that are meant
for you and you should keep walking
through them and I feel like I'm sitting
here today because I've just continued
to walk through the doors that stayed
open for me rather the ones that shut on
my face I mean you can use that in so
many way like relationships like every
you can use that it's a great metaphor
and it's that time of year when some of
us have started off with really good
intentions and plans to make pivots in
our lives not me I'm conquering them all
um but some of you may have lost a
little steam uh we have several people
in our audience with questions about
their life pivots for Jay so let's
answer some of those right now uh Bailey
has a question about moving forward so
Bailey go ahead hi Jay hey Bailey my
name is is Bailey and I was diagnosed
with brain cancer and at the age of 24
so I had about a year and a half going
through treatment and during that time I
listen to your podcast all the time I
listened before but I extra listened
during all of that um and so you know
that was a really my life was put on
pause for a little bit and then um I
finished my treatment I'm now 26
wow thank
you yeah so now I'm 26 and I'm going
back to the real world kind of my new
real world I should say um I'm in grad
school and I had like some different
questions to ask you because kind of
like my life was put on hold for for a
little bit while everyone else my age in
their 20s was moving forward I was kind
of on pause so I'm wondering if you had
any advice when you go through like a
setback in your life how to move forward
from it and how to and how to what's the
best advice to oh my God that's a huge
question it's a good one faile Wow first
of all you're so inspiring like
listening to you is inspiring me
honestly
that's unbelievable unbelievable I was I
was about to run up those steps and try
to give you a hug but I don't think it's
possible but uh maybe later but honestly
listening to your story makes me realize
that what it sounds like you're dealing
with is grief and a lot of us think of
grief as loss of someone we love but
grief can also be the loss of a life we
once had or time we thought we should
have had or could have had and I was
speaking to Katie kurck yesterday and
she shared this really beautiful thing
with me that I'd love to share with you
she was saying to me that grief is like
walking around with a rock in your
pocket and she was saying that in the
beginning every time you move you feel
that rock it might even scratch you it
hurts you and then she said as time goes
on the weight of that rock starts to
feel less and less and less it's not
that it goes away and it goes less and
less and less because you're growing at
the same time and I think one of the
best ways you could grow and I'd love
for you to try this is keep sharing your
inspiring stories with others I think if
you're helping other people carry their
weight then your weight starts to feel
less so I hope you'll try that out and
keep inspiring belly your your story is
phenomenal genuinely thank you so much I
appreciate big out I do think it's nice
even to shift your focus on others if
you're going through a hard time it help
helps a bit not the escapism of it but
just to lessen its power yes you know
thank you so much and congratulations
man
congrat it's a huge thing that happens
in your life well hadir has a question
about navigating rejection which I think
we all relate to hi Jay um I'm hadir I'm
so a little bit about me I'm 20 um 25
years old I just graduated pharmacy
school two years ago and in that time I
still have yet to find a permanent job
my mom and my dad tell me to put myself
out there to ask friends to apply at
different locations but unfortunately I
just feel
stuck um I feel tired I feel left behind
um and I don't I have a fear of asking
for help I have the fear of rejection
from like the hospitals and other places
so I just don't know what to do actually
I want to role play a little bit right
now if you're okay with it so can we get
a little ringtone sound ring ring there
we go perfect hey her how's it going
it's Jay hey Jay how you doing I'm doing
really well I'm doing really well what's
up nothing much well I heard that you
graduated a couple of years ago how's it
all going uh you know it's going just
living life
is there anything I can do for you um I
don't know I don't know I I truly I
guess um maybe help me uh contact if you
have connections that can help me I
guess yeah and what kind of connections
would you need um in hospitals that's
where I'm mainly looking at right now
that's brilliant hadir I'm going to
reach out to my network for Real uh and
see what I can do for you so thank you
so much for asking for help I appreciate
it well done thank you it wasn't so hard
right it wasn't so hard
it's so funny because I love how you
started because that is a thing I I
think a lot of us have a hard time with
like I'm always there like I love
helping people but it is very hard I had
to learn how to be able to because I
think sometimes we think it's we it's
it's a sign of weakness or something
we've been taught we think we're taking
something from someone but actually
you're giving them an opportunity to
shed kindness to spread kindness and
anyone who wants to do that is going to
take as an opportunity to want to
support you and so I want you to try
that out just practice it a few more
times and you'll nail it thank you so
much my dear just for
sharing and good luck maybe someone
listening right now on TV heard that she
would make a great employee in hospital
I'm just saying um well on purpose with
Jay Shetty is available wherever you get
your podcast Jay is also the chief
purpose officer for calm an app where
you can find his daily mindfulness
Series so check it
out
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home